là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ni non
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose que tout petit
détail le trophée les valises à paris
arrive à la bulle
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'inattendu
l'émission qui décrypte l'actualité
contemporaine grâce aux archives de la
télévision alors dans quelques minutes
nous allons parler de l'héritage
olympique tu es nous intéresserons
également à la politique avec le vote
déjà mais d'abord notre traditionnelle
revue de presse avec géraldine corner
lavaud et camille d'auxerre journaliste
à la rédaction de l'ina bonjour à nantes
les deux jours alors qu'amy vous avez
choisi de revenir sur les trahisons aux
rassemblements nationaux lui ment les
trahisons les désertions ce qui à
quelques mois quelques semaines de
l'échéance présidentielle quitte marine
le pen pour eric zemmour est bien la
famille d'extrême droite s'est déjà
déchiré c'était en
1998 c'était la guerre entre jean marie
le pen le président du front national et
son numéro 2 bruno mégret qui voulait
devenir numéro un et c'est l'implosion
jean-marie le pen a annoncé qu'il avait
suspendu de leur qualité d'adhérent
bruno mégret et quatre de ses proches la
querelle des chefs entraîne aujourd'hui
une implosion au front national
le président du front national appelle
tous les militants à rejoindre son camp
par l'intermédiaire de vos journaux
radios et télévisions jeudi pourtant aux
femmes et aux hommes du front national
et y ait pas de peine il faut
relativiser l'importance de cette
mutinerie face à la quasi totalité de
mes lieutenant rester dans la voie de la
fidélité et du dévouement à la cause
nationale je ne vous ai jamais menti
jamais abandonné jamais trahi
je suis un homme non d'extrême droite
mais d'extrême droite eurent confirmé
moi votre confiance
confirmée moi votre confiance il était
question pour jean marie le pen de faire
face à cette mutinerie du félon maigret
comme il l'appelait une mutinerie
jean-marie le pen avait d'ailleurs
qualifié de putsch
tout autre chose
géraldine un sujet un petit peu moins
grave peut-être un peu plus léger la
disparition des bistrots parisiens c'est
pas c'est pas léger du tout c'est très
grave nathanaël c'est même inquiétant
vous connaissez mon amour un pour les
bistrots et selon une étude de la
chambre de commerce le nombre de cafés
dans la capitale et sa petite couronne a
chuté de 40 % en 20 ans alors la
disparition des barres de la tradition
du café ou du jambon beurre accoudé au
zinc et ben c'est pas une inquiétude qui
est récente déjà en 1975 des habitués
d'un bistrot de belleville témoigner
j'aurais bien parler il se produit une
chose c'est que un type à cinq minutes
de retard ils hésitent à rentrer chez
lui parce que la soupe à la grimace
l'attend alors je suis une femme qu'il y
ait la gueule d'un espoir est bien mais
qu'il fuit cette atmosphère là et où
va-t-il bien bistrot mais s'ils sont
mieux que chez moi tous les soirs je
viens ici stand café de madame marcelle
avec une dame donner à manger aux chats
la jeune et libère en pas si je les aime
inutile de vous dire pour venir leur
donner à manger est revenu alors si
matin et alors on est contente de venir
chez marcel qu'on s'est un petit peu qui
on prend leur dit tellement oui et les
bistrots typique enfin comme ça mais
aussi simon gilbert peu après vont
disparaître et remplacé d'ailleurs ce
qui est terrible c'est que les bistrots
traditionnels sont ont démoli non
seulement des modiques mais pour les
modernisant les transformant en pub
anglais alors ce ne sont plus des
bistrots parisiens sont d'époque alors
voilà un des bistrots remplacés par des
peuples en 1975 aujourd'hui ils sont
plutôt en passer par des chaînes de
fast-food mais ces parisiennes 75
étaient plutôt visionnaire voilà moi ce
que j'aime c'est le petit café
croissants sur le zinc dans le journal
voilà pour l'actualité de cette semaine
alors que s'est il passé à cette même
période de l'année par le passé pour le
savoir regardez le zapping de
l'inattendu
bonjour
aurions-nous si vite oubliées comme en
est
cet abandon du pouvoir
l'essai au fort avec leurs crimes et
leurs sinistres 20
l'ex-dissidente diriger la birmanie
depuis 2000 16 ans côté des militaires
qu'ils viennent de l'arrêter
notre pays était comme un oiseau ils
apprenaient à voler
mais là l'armée nous a coupé les ailes
un record pour le premier jour dix-huit
mille visiteurs alors qu'on en attendait
que 8 me à 15 heures 7000 personnes
faisaient la queue pour entrer la
bibliothèque a été envahie par les
lecteurs le musée national d'art moderne
pris d'assaut à paris ce matin on ne se
culpabilise pas de quitter son poste
pour la pause clope
on perd pas plus de temps que les non
fumeurs qui blanc devant leur écran
je pense que l'élément principal de
cette mode et la jeunesse et surtout un
retour à des tendances jusque là un peu
oublié c'est à dire la simplicité le
naturel la souplesse des jeux dans
l'organisation atteint le gigantesque
jamais je pense en tout cas jamais c'est
certain ce qui concerne le jeu d'hiver
plein à relever autant de faste autant
de grandiose dans l'organisation
[Musique]
chaque semaine jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle l'inattendu va décrypter
la campagne et les thèmes abordés par
les candidats en remontant le temps
grâce aux archives de la télévision
alors à deux mois du premier tour on va
s'intéresser aujourd'hui au vote des
jeunes camille oui au vote des jeunes et
surtout à la manière dont les parties
étant de les inciter à voter parce que
les jeunes c'est une belle part du
gâteau pour les candidats à l'elysée il
faut les séduire d'après le dernier
sondage ipsos 54 % des 18-24 ans sont
certains d'aller voter à la
présidentielle ça veut dire donc si on
prend le chiffre à l'envers que 46 % des
jeunes n'iront peut-être pas voter à
cette élection présidentielle
alors tout est bon pour les inciter à
voter et ce depuis l'abaissement du
droit de vote à 18 ans en 1974 il serait
très bon que les jeunes puissent amener
un peu de fraîcheur à la politique avec
sincérité
juillet 1974 un vent de fraîcheur
souffle en politique sous l'impulsion de
valéry giscard d'estaing le droit de
vote passe de 21 à 18 ans on sent que ce
qu'on a un poids enfin quand on sait
qu'aux prochaines élections on va votre
eau c'est impressionnant où ça fait
plaisir
ça fait plaisir mais la crainte des
partis politiques c'est l'abstention des
jeunes or ils sont deux millions et demi
à voter pour la première fois à une
élection présidentielle en 1981 alors il
faut les éduquer à la politique les
jeunes giscardiens lance les universités
d'été du toit pourquoi vous êtes
c'est là parce que c'est là fait déjà
dix dernières
régis quart des saints nous a apporté un
grand renouveau de la politique et tous
les jeunes je pense sont reconnaissables
alors non pas tous les jeunes d'autres
sont à la fête de l'huma où se montre le
candidat communiste georges marchais
jacques chirac lui à ces comités de
jeunes dans les universités les lycées
ou d'ailleurs certains débutent leur
carrière politique
qu'attendez-vous de jacques chirac
écoutez les jeunes attendent jacques
chirac soit le président de la
république dont la france a besoin
qu'ils sachent parler le langage de
l'ambition d'espoir mais c'est françois
mitterrand qui gagne l'élection de 1981
avec notamment la voix des jeunes un
électorat qu'il veut conserver pour la
présidentielle de 1988 alors il dégaine
son monsieur eugène commence à voir
avec
jack lang il sillonne la france
rencontre les jeunes avec un message
qu'il martèle à qui veut bien l'entendre
il vous connaissez des jeunes voilà
les politiques tentent tout pour séduire
les jeunes vraiment tout jacques chirac
a bien change branches et rajeuni
groupies de madonna il multiplie les
interviews en destination des jeunes
podium nrj la radio des kinés hadjres en
1997 l'inscription des jeunes sur les
listes électorales devient automatique
mais ça n'empêche pas l'abstention il y
a vingt ans à la présidentielle de 2002
40 % d'entre eux n'ont pas voté et
l'extrême droite qualifié au premier
tour a été un électrochoc pour une
partie de la jeunesse jusqu'à un certain
21 avril il ne fallait surtout pas
parler de politique aux jeunes abattage
avait pas encore pris conscience
ce que la politique est primordiale au
pays
aussi la fille nancy je pense aller me
déplacer pour les vins sur ses listes
j'ai autre chose à faire il ya les
étudiants et là j'ai vraiment pris une
grosse claque branche thermique une
claque qui donne envie à certains jeunes
de s'engager politiquement depuis les
années 2000 les arènes politiques se
sont déplacés sur internet et les
réseaux sociaux
là où justement sont les jeunes l'elysée
multiplie les canaux de diffusion y
compris sur des réseaux sociaux très
prisé des plus jeunes snap chatte mêmes
tik tok les 18-24 ont un électorat très
courtisé mais qui au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 c'est
encore abstenus à 34%
34% d'abstention chez les jeunes c'était
le record toutes catégories confondues
dans la société en 2010 est aujourd'hui
pour l'élection certains candidats y
vont de leur petite proposition comme
anne hidalgo jean luc mélenchon qui
propose d'abaisser encore l'âge de vote
à 16 ans tout est bon donc pour séduire
cet électorat des 18 24 ans alors
peut-être rappeler que si l'inscription
sur les listes est automatique vous avez
jusqu'au 4 mars pour vérifier que vous
êtes bien inscrit en tout cas au bon
endroit pour pouvoir voter alors nos
jeunes ils sont abstentionnistes mais
ils ne sont pas des polos tizi
dépolitiser pour absolument ouais c'est
le moins qu'on puisse dire on les voit
ils manifestent ils sont dans la rue et
puis il y à une nouvelle application qui
a vu le jour il y a quelques semaines et
qui rencontre un certain succès ça
s'appelle élise et elle a été lancée par
des étudiants en école de commerce et la
presse en parle comme d'un teen d'heure
de la politique alors pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas tender c'est une
application de rencontre et bien et
lisez vous propose de suite à un petit
questionnaire de rencontrer un peu votre
alter ego politique de trouver pour vous
le candidat pour qui voter à cette
élection ah ben c'est pratique on va
essayer sa vérité
voilà et la semaine prochaine on
s'intéressera un nouveau thème de
campagne développée par par les
candidats
[Musique]
vendredi à pékin la flamme olympique
s'embrasera dans la capitale chinoise un
début de la 24e édition des jeux d'hiver
que laissent les jeux aux villes qui les
accueillent un héritage unique et
parfois un petit peu lourd à porter
bonjour marie barsacq alors vous êtes
responsable du projet impact et héritage
paris 2024 l'héritage des jeux c'est
votre dossier concrètement
qu'appelle-t-on héritage héritage en
général c'est tout ce qu'on laisse après
donc ce sont évidemment les
infrastructures qui sont laissées à la
ville qui organise les jeux et souvent
des infrastructures sportives alors
quelle est la promesse de pékin dont les
jeux d'hiver débutent cette semaine sur
ce sujet si important
alors c'est à la fois de pouvoir
réutiliser des équipements qui ont été
construits pour pékin-2008 souvenez vous
les jeux étaient à pékin en 2008 jo et
puis c'est aussi de développer une offre
sport d'hiver pour bien la classe
moyenne chinoise qui si nombreuses cette
notion de recyclage à elle est assez
récente au final dans l'histoire des
jeux moi je suis la caution archives
donc je vais vous montrer plein
d'archivés prenons l'exemple des jo de
grenoble en 1968 en voilà les images de
la cérémonie d'ouverture alors c'est
toute une ville qui avait été modifié
pour l'occasion des axes routiers un
hôtel de ville un aéroport un hôpital
tout une ville restructurer en à peine
deux ans et demi c'est énorme c'était la
volonté de l'état de changer grenoble et
toute sa région et quinze ans après le
bilan était plutôt mitigé depuis 15 ans
grenoble dispose de tous les équipements
sophistiqués
socioculturel et sportif cellulaire si
vous deviez recommencer l'expérience des
jeux olympiques en 1982 est ce que vous
feriez vêtements honnêtement je ne
recommencerai pas est-ce que grenoble
ressent encore le fardeau des jeux
olympiques quinze ans après il reste
bien entendu à payer en cas d un frein
mais honnêtement nous aurions dû au fil
des ans faire ce qui était fait deux ans
et demi et donc le fardeau soit encore
plus lourd donc on le voit un mitigé en
même temps il leur ferait pas mais en
même temps il reconnaît que ça a été un
accélérateur de projets donc en 1968
l'état mettez la main à la poche presque
sans compter et une fois la quinzaine
des jo au passé il restait quand même
des dettes à la ville aux collectivités
mais surtout à la ville de grenoble les
grenoblois ont remboursé jusqu'en
1995 les dettes des jo de 1968 est ce
que c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui
c'est que c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne et est ce que ça en vaut la
peine alors aujourd'hui pour paris 2024
c'est pas du tout le même modèle d'abord
financièrement nous les jeux finance les
jeux 97 % de notre budget qui est de 3
milliards vite et financé par des
acteurs privés avec les droits télé mais
aussi la billetterie et puis le
sponsoring et partenaires français qui
s'embarquent dans l'aventuré olympique
et paralympique donc ça déjà c'est
important de le dire et puis
deuxièmement le modèle le concept
s'appuie énormément sur de l'existant
95% des sites qui vont accueillir les
compétitions existe ou vont être
temporaire on va utiliser paris le
palais le grand palais le grand palais
est éphémère le champ de mars est de
versailles bref on valeur la scène des
équipements sportifs dans les sites
culturels parisiens on va créer ce choc
un peu culture et sport mais surtout on
va éviter de construire des équipements
qui n'aurait pas d'utilité après les
jeux et qu'on appelle des éléphants
blancs j'ai découvert cette expression
en préparant ce dossier par exemple un
éléphant blanc en france bien connu qui
date de 1968 c'est le tremplin construit
à saint nizier pour les jo de grenoble
et qui existe encore aujourd'hui mais ne
sert plus du tout
quelques points demain tout de même le
tremplin de saint nizier n'est utilisé
qu'une seule fois par an et encore
admirablement situé il donne aux
sauteurs l'impression de survoler
grenoble mais cela fait deux ans que
l'on ne veulent plus un sony zier est ce
que aujourd'hui le comité international
olympique est plus soucieux plus
attentif sur ces structures mais surtout
sur leur avenir comment ils vont être
utilisés après les jo oui complètement
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il a produit
un agenda 20 20 est cet agenda 20-20
donne des recommandations pour toutes
les villes qui candidatent et les
recommandations évidemment son lien avec
la lutte contre les éléphants blancs
comment les éviter au maximum mais aussi
comment engager la population pour
qu'elle soutienne les jeux et comment
aussi penser un modèle de jeu qui soit
durable respectueux de la planète alors
malgré les garde-fous imposé par le cio
il ya déjà eu
par le passé des flops retentissants
athènes en 2004 avait laissé des sites à
l'abandon comme rio en 2016 on a en
images un en mémoire dont ces images un
des stades laissé à l'abandon des
piscines vides et rouillée là on voit
c'est à athènes c'était le circuit de
canoë-kayak évident qui rouille et
pourtant à rio il était prévu que des
infrastructures soient recyclés par
exemple en école ça n'a pas été le cas
rien n'a été recyclés écouté par exemple
le responsable héritage de rio
en cyclisme sur piste on n'avait qu'un
seul coureur brésilien aux jo mais
désormais nous avons la piste la plus
rapide du monde et j'espère qu'on va
pouvoir découvrir de nouveaux talents
qui participeront aux prochains jeux
olympiques c'est tout l'objet de ces
installations
dans un rapport muscler le procureur
fédéral me thierry affirme aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y avait pas de vrais plans
d'héritage olympique pour rio-2016 et on
exige qu'on se mette à pratiquer ce
sport parce que maintenant après avoir
construit deux vélodrome il faut bien
qu'on devienne champion de cyclisme sur
piste
est ce que c'est ça l'exemple parfait
d'un flop c'est qu'on n'a pas étudié ce
qui allait se passer après est ce que
vous le dossier de rio par exemple
d'athens des choses que vous avez
épluché pour préparer paris oui bien sûr
les éplucher on a passé du temps à
comprendre ce qu'il y avait moins bien
marché le seuil eux aussi est très
soucieux de sa vous l'évoquez dans le
dans le sujet le plan d'héritage de
l'équipement n'a pas été pensée
aujourd'hui le cio exige des comités
d'organisation donc nous doit fournir un
plan après les jeux un business plan
pour être sûr que l'équipement qu'on
construit va bien avoir un modèle
économique qui permettra à cet
équipement de vivre après les jeux donc
ça aujourd'hui il ya des garde fous
proposé par le seuil haut et puis aussi
par les comités d'organisation eux mêmes
qui se veulent être responsable c'est
aussi nous un enjeu énorme de réputation
par rapport évidemment l'organisation
des jeux dans notre pays nous ont
construit un seul équipement sportif
déjà par rapport aux éléphants blancs
rio ils en construisent et une douzaine
donc pour une ville comme rio 12
équipements avec douze plants d'héritage
pour leurs populations s'assurer qu'ils
aient des championnats du monde qui
viennent dans ses équipements ses
faramineux alors à la fin je le flamme
s'éteint le cio s'en va existe-t-il je
sais pas si c'est le bon mot mais une
sorte de sav héritage olympiques c'est à
dire que le cio va bien vérifier que le
stade qui devait devenir école va bien
devenir écoles ou que la piscine qui
devait venir piscine municipale va bien
devenir piscine municipale le cio fait
ce sav il a fait ce sav aussi avec les
jeux de encore et de pyongyang puisque
tu me chambrent a créé une fondation
après les jeux avec le soutien du
seigneur et à rio par exemple ils font
quoi le savez du célé lot
pour lesquels c'est un peu plus
compliqué que d'autres voilà donc il
faut il faut évidemment dire les choses
mais quand c'est possible cio accompagne
les villes et puis les comités
d'organisation alors les comités
d'organisation évidemment fin ferme la
porte quand même après les jeux là celui
de tokyo justement pour s'assurer que
l'héritage soit bien au rendez vous il
va continuer à vivre plus longtemps que
d'habitude au moins un an après les jeux
ce qu'ils vont organiser un grand
événement pour célébrer les un an des
jeux en septembre l'année prochaine
alors il n'y a pas que des ratés
heureusement pour les gigots il ya aussi
des réussites on pense à barcelone en
1992 ou londres en 2012 donc barcelone
qui avait réinventé complètement sa
ville la tournée vers vers la
méditerranée ou londres en 2012 qui a
complètement métamorphosé un quartier et
avaient misé aussi sur des structures
démontables regarde que vont devenir les
installations olympiques pour éviter de
tomber dans le piège des olympiades
précédent du gouffre économique pour
certaines villes organisatrices bien les
britanniques on anticipait l'après jeux
et ils ont construit leurs sites dans un
esprit de recyclage on a commencé dans
l'heure qui a suivi la fin des matches
une bonne partie de la structure servira
pour d'autres événements majeurs comme
les jeux de sotchi où rio
utiliser des structures éphémères et
donc réutilisables
c'était le pari de londres 2012 faire
des sites en kit
grâce à ça on épargne à la mairie de
londres des frais d'entretien inutile
pour un endroit qui ne seraient plus
utilisé
est ce que c'est ça la clé c'est de
d'avoir des structures mon table
démontable qu'on peut mettre dans des
différentes qu'on peut peut-être
revendre aux éditions suivantes aussi
oui c'est sur l'économie circulaire
aujourd'hui c'est une préoccupation
majeure pour nous pour l'aménagement des
sites de compétition mais pour tous les
achats de paris 2024 puisqu'on a un code
d'achat comment on achète on pose des
questions dans nos marchés quand on
lance un appel d'offres est la première
question qu'on pose c'est que
faites-vous en matière d'économie
circulaire et notre objectif c'est pas
forcément d'acheter du produit neuf mais
c'est aussi de pouvoir nous utiliser un
produit qui a déjà été utilisé et puis
qu'il se produit soit recyclés après
récupérer les tribunes de rio pour paris
2024 par exemple ou celle de tokyo qui
sont encore plus encore plus récente
exactement là on verra ça c'est sûr les
tribunes mais en tout cas ça se fait sur
tous nos produits en fait c'est ça qui
est intéressant sur notre mobilier par
exemple on a emménagé l'année dernière
dans un site en seine saint denis tous
notre mobilier et à un mobilier de
recyclage donc c'est l'immobilier qui a
d'abord été
construits sur des produits recyclés
mais en plus ce qui a déjà été utilisée
par d'autres entreprises avant nous et
pourquoi ne pas utiliser un site unique
pour faire les jeux olympiques tout tous
les quatre ans
alors peut-être qu'on passe à côté de la
magie des pays parce que pour un pays
accueillir les jeux c'est c'est une
fierté incroyable
en tout cas c'est pour ça qu'on s'est
engagé dans cette aventure pour faire
rêver tous les français à porter de la
fierté de l'émotion et ça c'est aussi
quelque chose qui se construit à
l'échelle d'un pays peut-être et pas
forcément à l'échelle de la planète un
lieu unique pour ceux qui défendent
cette cette proposition ça permettrait
aussi de réduire les coûts écologiques
des jeux souvenez vous par exemple
sotchi en russie en 2014 ce sont les jo
les plus chers de l'histoire un tenez
vous bien 36 milliards d'euros et
désastres écologiques
ici il ya cinq ans il y avait une
réserve naturelle des marais des oiseaux
migrateurs et une plage connus des seuls
initiés
aujourd'hui bétonner la plage a perdu
tout son cachet quant à la mère elle est
impropre à la baignade selon les normes
internationales
car les abords du parc olympique ont été
abandonnées des décharges à ciel ouvert
qui existent par dizaines
je t'ai je repensais je le pensais
justement aux jeux de sotchi
ce pari seront différents seront utiles
vers oui on a une promesse à cet égard
50% de réduction de l'empreinte carbone
par rapport à londres alors je vous le
disais tout à l'heure c'est 50% sont
possibles parce qu'on construit peut
parce que souvent la construction génère
pas mal d'empreinte carbone donc là on
construit peu et puis on met en place un
modèle d'achat différend avec modèle
d'économie circulaire tout ce qu'on fait
on le pense pour réduire au maximum
notre empreinte carbone il ya une
empreinte qu'on peut pas réduire c'est
le déplacement des spectateurs et des
athlètes pour tout le reste on se pose
la question et on essaie de faire au
mieux les constructions si par exemple
du village c'est la construction de la
piscine vous avez parlé mais il ya la
construction de ces villages voilà du
village pour les aplats qui a des
conséquences quand même aujourd'hui ou
ou futurs sur le coût écologique alors
il est pensé vraiment comme un éco
quartier ce village et il est d'abord
comme pour la piscine pensé pour
répondre à des attentes du territoire la
seine saint denis un territoire qui
manquent de logements donc ce projet
vient répondre aux problématiques de
logement donc on construit d'abord un
quartier un écoquartier d'ailleurs on
construit une crèche une école un
collège il des commerces et des terrains
de sport bref c'est vraiment un quartier
qui est pensé et c'est la même logique
pour le village des médias qui va être
construit autour de dugny le bourget ont
également que l'héritage vous tient le
plus à coeur dans ces jeux de paris en
2000 vainqueur alors pour l'héritage et
matériels en fait c'est celui sur lequel
on travaille aussi beaucoup qui est
celui de faire une place plus forte au
sport dans notre société que les
français est une autre perception du
sport donc on connaît les français très
férue de culture et bien on aimerait
bien qu'après 2024 il soit féru de sport
et qu'ils pratiquent beaucoup plus pour
leur santé bien sûr mais aussi pour leur
bien-être et pour une meilleure jean
nationale ont parlé de la scène qui sera
le théâtre de la cérémonie
d'ouverture imaginez que on nage dans la
scène ça peut être un héritage de des
jeux de paris c'est vrai que c'était le
cas en 1945 en garde et on a retrouvé
ses images gc ca paris même dans la
seine
alors c'est une promesse effectivement
inattendue pour faire un point avec
votre émission
l'on y travaille il ya beaucoup de
travaux en ce moment sur le sujet c'est
la nage en eau vive qui aura lieu dans
la seine il ya tout tout est réuni
aujourd'hui pour s'assurer qu'en cas de
conditions climatiques catastrophiques
on puisse le faire à une petite échelle
de la scène mais l'ambition c'est
vraiment de rendre la scène baignable
donc je vous donne rendez-vous en 2024
en maillot de bain et plaisir retrouvera
avec plaisir au bord de la scène marie
barsacq
responsable du projet impact héritage
pour les jeux de paris en 2024 et merci
à vous géraldine dernière avoir fait
revivre ces bons moments olympique
de l'histoire on se quitte avec notre
traditionnel pépites et on va rester
avec les jeux olympiques à les mascottes
de pékin 2022 sont un petit panda est
une lanterne lantern est à droite bic
douane doit échoir en drones alors
saviez-vous que l'invention des
mascottes pour les jo et française et
oui tout la preuve la première mascotte
c'était en
1968 aux jeux de grenoble regardez cette
mascotte s'appelait schultz étirez vous
étiez vous êtes resté pendant une
quinzaine de jours à mexico pour la
semaine et olympique vous ne connaissez
donc pas ce petit bonhomme à 1000 savez
vous comment il s'appelle ah non je ne
sais pas du tout il ya des appels
schultz
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dixièmes jeux olympiques d'hiver
voilà j'adore schultz marie la mascotte
paris 2024 oui elle est dans les cartons
elle sortira en septembre on peut savoir
comment elle va s'appeler a pas encore
sans nom n'a même pas été choisi encore
le on se retrouve en tout cas la semaine
prochaine sur le canal 27 et toute la
semaine sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit ceux de l'inao sur france info
émission préparée avec les
documentalistes viviane barney et mini
galtier merci à elle et merci à vous
d'être là chaque semaine
[Musique]